the United States stands ready to find
common ground with Russia as long as the
two of us can engage seriously on those
issues we discussed this foreign
minister Lavrov said many important
topics we talked about terrorism we
talked about Afghanistan president
Trump's made clear that his expectation
is that we will have an improved
relationship between our two countries
this will benefit each of our peoples
and I think that our talks here today
were a good step in that direction
a few subjects that we talked about for
minister Lavrov mentioned that we spoke
about Syria
we both want to move forward on the
political track to bring the suffering
of the Syrian people to an end and we
want to do so in a way that ensures that
Syria will never again be haven for
Islamist terrorist groups I also raised
our concern about the escalation of the
situation around it live in the
northwest of Syria
we also discussed North Korea and its
nuclear program the United States and
Russia agree on the goal of the
denuclearization we'll continue to
discuss it i underscore that we must
maintain full implementation of the UN
sanctions until the final fully verified
denuclearization of North Korea is
achieved and our two teams have been
working very closely together on this in
a very productive fashion on Venezuela
we have disagreements I urge my Russian
colleagues to support the Venezuelan
people as they return democracy to their
country the United States and more than
50 other nations agree that the time has
come for Nicolas Maduro to go he's
brought nothing but misery to the
Venezuelan people and we hope that
Russians support for Maduro will end but
despite our disagreements we'll keep
talking I hope we can find a way for
that ends with the humanitarian
political crisis that is happening on
this we both agree we also discussed the
situation Ukraine the Trump
administration has been clear that we do
not recognize Russia's attempted
annexation in Crimea and we hope that we
can continue to move forward our
sanctions have remained in place
I urged Russia to reach out to Ukraine's
new president to demonstrate leadership
by taking step towards breaking the
stalemate
we wouldn't particularly welcome the
release of the Ukrainian crewmen
detained near the Kerch Strait last year
and we talked about implementation and
how we might move forward in obtaining a
ceasefire in the Donbass region we spoke
a bit about the activities that are
taking place in the Middle East today
with particular focus on the actions
that Iran is taking I've made clear that
the United States will continue to apply
pressure to the regime in Tehran until
its leadership is prepared to return to
the ranks of responsible nations that do
not threaten their neighbors are spread
instability or terror as foreign
minister Lavrov alluded to very much on
president Trump's mind his arms control
our actions on the INF treaty have
demonstrated that were committed to
effective arms control that advances us
allied and partner security that is
verifiable and enforceable the president
has charged his national security team
to think more broadly about arms control
to include countries beyond our
traditional US Russia framework and a
broader range of weapons systems we
president wants serious arms control
that delivers real security to the
American people and we know and I think
we agree on this to achieve these go
goals we'll have to work together and
that it would be important that if it's
possible we get China involved as well
we'll have a more extensive set of
conversations both about arms control
and a opportunity to discuss all broad
strategic security issues between our
two countries
in the weeks ahead I also raised the
issue of US citizens who have been
detained in Russia making sure that our
citizens are not unjustly held abroad as
one of president Trump's highest
priorities and we spoke to about the
question of interference in our domestic
affairs I contained that there are
things that Russia can do to demonstrate
that these types of activities are a
thing of the past and I hope that Russia
will take advantage of those
opportunities finally I wanted to
emphasize the
and friendship with the Russian people
our two nations share proud histories
and respect for one another's cultures
we seek a better relationship with
Russia and we urge that it work
alongside the trajectory of the
relationship each of our peoples to want
to prolong the treaty thank you so
foreign minister Lavrov raised the issue
of concerns about compliance with New
START treaty today we'll continue to
work to allow that tree to be verified
exactly as the verification regime
exists as for its extension what we've
agreed that we will do is we will gather
together teams that will begin to work
not only on new start and it's it's
potential extension but on a broader
range of arms control issues that each
of our two nations have I think in our
shared best interest achieving an
agreement on Muskoka says no as for our
position indeed we have concerns that
have to do repeating the u.s. launchers
Trident SLBM as well as heavy bombers of
converting them to non nuclear forces
starting the treaty forces that allows
for the party
the assumption that within the bilateral
consultative commission and guessing do
the guesswork what happened or not and
that's what we will do thinks we're
gonna go to guy Benson from Fox News
thank you very much I want to follow up
on Venezuela mr. secretary what was the
message from the Trump administration
specifically in regards to the Russian
government and their continued support
of Nicolas Maduro and their active
involvement in the Western Hemisphere
and mr. foreign minister why is it the
Russian government persists in
supporting mr. Maduro when virtually
every democracy in Latin America has
recognized mr. Guido as the legitimate
interim leader of that country thank you
we talked about this for some time
we made clear the u.s. position we want
every country that's interfering in
Venezuela to cease doing that we want
the Venezuelan people to get their
democracy back they want them to have a
fair free election elect their own
leadership not in the way that the sham
election took place with mr. Maduro so
whether it's Iranian forces or Chinese
or Cubans
the Trump administration's position is
that they all need to cease having an
impact in supporting Maduro and allowing
the Venezuelan people not only to get
their democracy back but give them an
opportunity to rebuild this country that
has tremendous wealth our Russian
companies operating there that are
successful businesses as well we want we
want those countries we want the country
to get a chance to rebuild its economy
to so that it it isn't dependent on
humanitarian assistance from anywhere in
the world but rather they can begin to
deliver economic outcomes for themselves
and to do that the central point is that
we need free and fair elections they're
not interfere by any other nation it's
not Sherpas it's as for our positions in
response to your question why Russia is
taking for such a stance then as well as
themselves with no ultimatums and no
preconditions from the fact that
democracy cannot be the threats that we
hear again representatives or US
administration is right to lose military
intervention outside this has nothing in
common with democracy
remember back in 2003 that was made
remember 2011 it was declared Muammar
Gaddafi was no
he's a democracy I don't think I should
go into more detail on how the democracy
feels itself in Iran and Libya Russia 24
channels Bugaboo him in Istanbul was
motioning to Putin will trump Pomfret
ichiba us to park in pharmacopoeia but
he still caused Iran no pasadenian
overstate promotional Prosecco voice of
pollution accosted three worn as much as
distribution cronies Louisville in Iran
with European leaders on board with you
on that is the solution later well
naturally we heard statements by
President Trump that he was facts to
hold a meeting with President Putin and
we talked about that today with Michael
pump here let me talk about my
conversations and Brussels and then more
broadly about its policy with respect to
the Islamic Republic of Iran so I went
to Brussels to share with our European
friends the threats and concerns we have
about actions that the Iranians are
taking or potentially taking and we want
to make sure they understood the risks
as we saw them and I shared I shared
that with them in in some detail
as for our policy it's been consistent
now for the entire Trump administration
and the decision to withdraw from the
jcpoa now just over a year ago I made
clear what our objective
we laid them out in May of last year
we're looking for Iran to behave like a
normal country and that's our ask and we
have applied pressure to the leadership
of the Islamic Republic around to
achieve that we we fundamentally do not
see a war with Iran we're looking for
the regime to simply stop conducting
assassination campaigns throughout
Europe to cease their support of
Hezbollah that threatens interests all
across the Middle East their support for
the Houthis that are launching missiles
into areas where there are Russians and
Americans traveling these missiles could
easily kill a Russian or an American we
laid them out in some detail our
position hasn't changed and the movement
of troops that you described I'll leave
to the Department of Defense but we've
also made clear to the Iranians that if
American interests are attacked we will
most certainly respond in an appropriate
fashion Shaun Tandon AFP great thank you
thanks for your time I wanted to follow
up on a couple of statements he said
first for foreign minister Lavrov you
mentioned that despite the disagreements
with Iran that there's a possibility of
certain agreements on Iran going for it
could explain what what you see in
common with the u.s. and Iran where you
can go if I could ask you about the
mysterious incidents in the UAE
rewriting the oil tankers have you
pinpointed responsibility for that and I
can follow up in your statement about
the election you said that there are
things that Russia could do to show that
election interference is a thing of the
past
what what are those things what do you
what would you like Russia to do thank
you very much like I said
until we have information which there
contemplation a real much respected by
me
confirmed that no they're not prepared
for that so draw your own conclusions
you can see we have some disagreements
on this issue I promise not to go back
to history from the early 30s but I made
clear to for mr. Lavrov as we've made
clear for the past months that
interference and American elections is
unacceptable the Russians were engaged
in that in 2020 it would put our
relationship in an even worse place than
it has been and encourage them not to do
that that we would we would not tolerate
that you know we've said this not only
about the Russians but about other
countries as well are our elections are
important and sacred and they must be
kept free and fair and with no outside
country interfering in those elections
your first question was about what we
know about the attacks that took place
off the United Arab Emirates they don't
have any information than I
can share with you yet about the nature
of what took place there
we're working diligently to get answers
to what caused those those ships to have
the problems that they have today
gentlemen and that concludes our
presence thank you for taking part